I am a huge advocate a an apostle for a
new national conversation I think we
need to be it doesn't have to and you
can make that sound so somber and so
austere that it's a big turnoff you know
we need a new national conversation we
must all be beard strokers it that ain't
it I'm talking about people sitting down
in their own neighborhoods and their own
communities and talking about making
sense out of what's going on around us
and not being willing to settle for echo
chamber sound bites from major media
news platforms that are preaching a
particular point of view oh that's okay
take that as a point of departure I'm
talking about individuals communities
families business groups professions
sitting down and using the opportunity
of a cup of coffee on a regular basis or
a webcast on a regular basis to stage
their own talk show where they ask a new
question why are we doing this do we
know what we're doing does it matter are
we achieving something that contributes
do we do we have the right questions
here right are we even plugged into the
right questions that conversation if
America and America has them still the
most powerful country in the world
engages in that question exercise that's
got real power to it and real urgency to
it so I I opted for finding a way to get
that to happen whether it's through a
book project a video project a web
engagement however you do it don't be so
don't be too serious don't be self
important try to relax and take a breath
and enjoy the ride but get into the game
of talking about the future you want to
create and then how would you do it how
would you go about creating